hello I'm Don Lemon and I'm Anderson
Cooper and you're watching the wired
summer rather interview that's right
that's right I've only ever seen all of
Jonathan's work and all of the wire
things that we're doing seeing them all
so we're ready we're primed for this
[Music]
how did Paul Rudd become Ant-Man
so who answers this which one am I
looking in you walked us through it I
know I did but then there was something
this one over here how did how did Paul
Rudd uh become in with a very solid
understanding of which camera to look
into oh kid thus Paul Rudd actually like
rush I actually do like rush I did a
movie called I love you man in the movie
my character Peter Clavin loves rush and
Jason Siegel's character loves rush and
we both really do like rush and Rush
came and filmed a day on our films um
they filmed a day on our film you got it
it was a rush it was a total rush it was
amazing well done sir I'm here for you
when did Paul Rudd start acting great
question really great question really
great
1947. when he was a boy back when I was
a boy selling pickles on Orchard Street
everyone was in New York everything was
happening we were all we were just
living stacked on top of each other I
knew back then that I wanted to be an
aunt when does Paul Rudd come on Parks
and Rec oh I I think it was in season
four that I was on
um Parks and Rec uh and what a blast the
first episode that I was on well I
but of course Bobby Newport uh you know
sweetums who are Paul Rudd's friends in
real life
well let me take this one no go ahead
it's your card it's your card Jonathan
Majors that's my friend we're out of
here
can I get that back please who else
besides Jonathan majors are your friends
in real life all right friends in real
life
um I don't want to reveal the identity
of any of my other friends
it's quite satisfying who is Jonathan
Majors period that's it that's no
question who is he in Ant-Man in Ant-Man
I play Kane the Conqueror a time
traveling Nexus being villain what does
that mean a Nexus being villain means
I'm everywhere oh great
where Jonathan majors in Loki now make
that question what you want I think
where where uh uh where where where
Jonathan majors in Loki in Loki uh where
Jonathan
where Jonathan majors in low this is a
he who remains question I am assuming I
am at the end of time there there's a
bit of a citadel that I dwell in all
right here we go how did Jonathan Majors
train for Creed Three oh creep through
the boxing picture and uh lots of boxing
road work is probably the most uh
intense part of boxing that's the uh
push-ups surrounding the jump ropes bag
work I probably trained for Creeds for
uh probably eight eight to nine months I
believe it cook them with gas we're
cooking with gas now here we go all
right here we go here we go Jonathan
Majors devotion which is a beautiful
movie about a young man named ensign
Jesse Leroy Brown was the first uh black
Naval aviator and a American uh hero and
a hero of mine great picture hold on
just a second
why was Paul Rudd voted sexiest man
tabulation it's quite obvious isn't it
why is Paul Rudd a Chiefs fan I'm a
chief fan because I grew up in Kansas
City and uh and so
why was Paul Rudd not in the office
couldn't afford him
uh why did Paul run hardly I wish
cauliflower oh was it for hot ones in
hot ones I didn't eat the chicken wings
I ate cauliflower because I want to
support vegetarian I think it's a you
know I think it's a cool thing plus
sometimes I get a little weirded out
with chicken wings
why Paul red calling Thor's hammer John
Paul Rudd calling throws everything
who writes these you don't like
conjunctions do you why not
why not
oh here we go speed round what is
Jonathan majors
favorite movie oh God would be faster
Homeward Bound
yeah what is Jonathan Majors workout
routine pain what is Jonathan Major's
zodiac sign Virgo
uh Capricorn uh Rising uh sorry
Sagittarius Rising Capricorn
yeah I knew it you can feel it what does
Jonathan Majors eat gasoline and uh
rocks food food yeah eat it yeah
okay oh man look at this does Paul Rudd
have two different colored eyes that's
how mystical you are like Bowie I don't
have two different colored eyes my eyes
are both the same color and but they do
change colors which is weird they always
have did Paul Rudd work at
Baskin-Robbins not not in real life no I
didn't I only you didn't commit I didn't
take the job I wasn't hired
I couldn't afford you that's the thing
does Paul Rudd like One Direction like
One Direction you know what I do they're
not those are they're nice boys I hosted
SNL in One Direction oh it was uh the
band and uh they were just Charming guys
I don't know what happened to any of
them but I sure liked it when I uh when
I met them did Paul Rudd sing and
Veronica Mars I did I did sing in
Veronica Mars uh I played a guy named
Desmond fellows that show was created by
buddies of mine we all kind of worked
created the show party down together
we've been friends for a long time and I
had a great time working as Desmond on
Veronica Mars and I did get to sing
indeed does Paul Rudd get royalties from
friends I don't believe that I do and uh
is that any of their business that's
like Financial personal information I
don't think I don't think I did I don't
think that um you won't after this I'd
say that much do you know that there was
a bar in Los Angeles it used to be that
if you got a check for under a residual
check for something you did and it was
under a dollar you could take to this
bar called residuals and they'd give you
a beer and they take your check and pin
it on the wall and used to go in this
bar it was all filled everything was
just
it was a really smart uh business plan I
think because you're gonna buy more
beers are you are you now Partners uh in
this I own I own residuals all right
here we go
does Jonathan Mage does Jonathan major
sing Oh yes I know he does did Jonathan
Majors go to Yale yes yes smarty pants
Jonathan Majors do his own stunts yes
does John yes
he does dance what don't you do
final round final round where is Paul
Rudd's candy store it's in Rhinebeck New
York it's called Samuel sweet shop I own
it with Jeffrey Dean Morgan and Hillary
Burton
and my wife and a guy named Andy ostroy
what movie does Paul Rudd order
Starbucks or Starbucks in the movie role
models uh I order uh in a Starbucks and
I order a large black coffee and that's
right out of my life was Paul Rudd a
sigma new I was I went to a University
of Kansas for about a couple years do
you have steps
the steps like you
doing steps you could do oh I don't know
I never learned them if I I got out of
there pretty soon
I remember got the steps I don't know
what do I mean
is Paul Ryan
it only murderers in the building I am
I'm doing a little bit on that show only
murders in the building and it is a
little more than Cameo a little less
than Cameo no more no it's a little more
than a cameo
um a little more than residuals a little
less than resistors
go in and get a free beer that's good
that is good that's why you own candy
shop can pull Rudd oh
hey Paul can you do close up Magic
that's something you're capable of doing
wait what is that in here
oh my God
the answer is yes
should Google what movies will Paul and
Johnson makers do next maybe Homeward
Bound too there's already been a
heartbound too there's homework balance
home event lost in San Francisco come on
man who do you want to be sassy I'll be
Paul Simon and you could be our
girlfriend I'd probably chance oh I
think we're talking about the different
Homeward bounds
typical foreign